c'est en france jimmy page
donc on va faire une interview fromage
ou dessert est ce que vous préférez les
stones sous les beatles intéressante
parce que les beatles alors qu'un début
je n'ai pas pris très au sérieux
il faisait des chansons qu'on brise mais
c'est aux femmes at-elle en premier
album ça m'a pas beaucoup frappé ça va
pas interpellé dix ans quand ils ont
commencé à faire blue jay walsh des prix
beaucoup plus au sérieux
et quand ils ont enregistré ça va durer
quelques années seulement il est certain
que les beatles
on développe se sont développées de
manière absolument phénoménale
c'est une force de la nature en tête
alors que les rolling stones pour moi
j'ai toujours adoré parce que il venait
en fait et même origine qu'eux mais
c'est à dire le newser malibu comme ça
est ce que vous préférez mick jagger et
keith richards
je peux parler à qui je fais pas avec
d'accord est ce que vous préférez
john lennon et paul mccartney
probablement john nom john à coup sûr
même alors est ce que vous préférez que
vos enfants se droguent ou qu'ils
écoutent britney spears
écoutez tout respire c'est un peu une
drogue surtout si on est un peu obsédé
par elle et les solutions dans les spas
le disque on le fait on le passe en
boucle
mais mes enfants et ils adorent enfin il
se drogue à l'air à dakar très bien est
ce que vous préférez quand pirates vos
albums ou que plus personne ne les
écoute
en vérité avec led zeppelin
il y avait des cassettes à l'époque
c'était à cette différence tous les
soirs henin il y avait une partie été
échantillonnée qui arrivait chez et puis
il ya une période malheureuse de
brimades
j'ai essentiellement divorce et j'ai
quitté la maison et qui est des gens qui
se sont acoquinés avec mon ex femme et à
ce titre ils ont piqué en fait tous ces
échantillons s'étaient tous les concerts
qui a monté à des années des années
jusqu'en 1980 et également des
enregistrements de deux répétitions de
tout alors si vous pensez à un viol
musicale - une espèce de drogue
voilà vous avez un bel exemple mais
c'était malheureux et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il y avait tellement de
2,2 bon piratage y avait des bandes
maîtresses est ce que vous préférez la
première guerre en irak où la deuxième
alain plus fun j'ai pas de préférence
tranquille ou pour l'autre
est ce que vous préférez une bonne
bouffe ou une baisse moyenne oui qu'il
s'agisse de bouffe ou de baisse se
serait toujours un banquet pour moi
d'accord
jimmy est ce que vous préférez votre
femme ou votre maîtresse la guitare à
meknès la bonne réponse
merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linda hardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu